my name is for kyocera me senior partner
devotional sucking in Latin America many
people who ask us what is the biggest
ant I'm a potential of Latin America and
many people have already said that
lovely medium decayed intention using
with natural resources the largest
reserves of Yom Kippur oil gas say it
will be a key element which My Chemical
continue to the world but I did believe
that the keeper condition and the
untapped potential would be a talent of
Latin Americans the talent of all these
entrepreneurs that are fostering
innovation to solve many prongs of the
visual half and think about the future
and the needs for talent to really
transform businesses and countries and
societies we firmly believe that what
America will distinguish yourself
through the development recent
e-commerce innovation and changes to the
modes of God today